I really like this Ben Carson guy but do
we really need another black president
dad please the girls eat a lot
is there anything besides Turkey makes
me all bloated you're hosting relatives
for the holidays and it's awful you just
wish you could press a fast-forward
button to get to the end yes do you have
one of those
what no there's no technology that
speeds up time but there is something
else well is that Paula gets one call of
this lever and you'll release enough
epoxy flooring sleeping gas Roger all
house to make sure everyone and it
passes out and he stays asleep for five
to six hours straight until it's time to
go home
just sweet uninterrupted sleep to pass
the time great for you great for your
guests great for spokesmen like me who
have no place to be on the holidays no
one reached out to me
[Music]
[Music]
to make the holidays pass use Halle gas
[Music]
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography